welcome back folks uh we'll get ready
with the afternoon session uh pleased to
have uh
delta presenting on algorithmic fairness
from the lens of modality
thank you so much for having me here
today
so today i'll be presenting my research
on algorithmic fairness
which synthesizes tools from causality
and information theory
in particular an emerging body of work
with an information theory called
partial information decomposition
so i'll start with the motivation
so machine learning is entering into
almost every aspect of our lives these
days
including these really high stakes
applications such as hiring education
lending healthcare etc
for instance roughly 40 percent of
companies today are using machine
learning to assist in various stages of
their hiring process
so while these models are really great
at learning all patterns present in the
data
but blindly learning all patterns can
sometimes lead to unintended
consequences
like propagating biases with respect to
gender race age nationality etc
that can have serious undesirable
consequences
on people's lives
and in many cases
is also disallowed by law
when it comes to addressing these legal
disputes or even informing policies and
interventions
only identifying bias at the output of a
model is not always sufficient
and we really need to dig deeper and
understand another important question
that bridges both fairness and
explainability
that is how do we identify and explain
the sources of bias in machine learning
models
so let us understand this question
through an example
we consider a scenario of hiring a
software engineer for a safety critical
application
we have a bunch of input features that
go into a model
and the model decides whether to hire or
not
[Music]
now these features could be things like
coding test score aptitude test score
etc
now the first thing to do is to avoid
biases with respect to gender race etc
we stop using these sensitive attributes
as inputs to the model
but again it has been found that even if
you do not use them explicitly as inputs
the output could still be strongly
correlated with gender or race because
the other features are correlated
and the legal motivation for this is
also disparate impact which refers to
policies or practices that affect some
group of individuals
more adversely than others even if it is
not intentional
but then
sometimes there are some features that
are more important than others
like coding test score might be really
critical to the hiring of a software
engineer
this is where it becomes important that
how did the disparity arise did it arise
primarily due to the coding test score
or were the other features also
responsible
and even the law says that disparate
impact may be exempt if it can be
justified by an occupational necessity
like coding test score may be critical
for the software engineering job
weightlifting ability may be critical in
the hiring of firefighters
but then aptitude test may not be
critical as in this landmark court case
of griggs versus duke power
so this motivates our problem that i'll
state informally now
that given a choice of critical features
how do we say if the disparity is exempt
or non-exempt
and towards answering this question
my work provides a systematic measure of
non-exam disparity
which is the bias that is not justified
by the given critical features
so algorithmic fairness in general is a
growing field of research with several
interesting works in the last few years
the problem that i am interested in is
that of understanding these feature
based contributions to disparity
and i'm trying to quantify this non-exam
disparity using partial information
decomposition and causality which has
received less attention
so my outline for the talk will be
something like this
i will be spending most of my time on
this problem of finding a measure of
non-exam disparity
and after that i will briefly touch upon
some other related problems that i am
also working on
i will now start with this problem
statement
and some notations first
so let z denote the protected attribute
like gender rays age etc
then we have a bunch of features that
will go into a model
and the model output is denoted by y hat
now the critical features will be
denoted by xc
and all the other non-particular general
features are denoted by xg
and we also assume that there is an
underlying causal model or data
generation process which generates all
of these features
where this u1 u2 u3 are some underlying
latent factors that we do not usually
observe all the time
now the problem statement is given a
choice of critical features
what is a good measure of non-exam
disparity
which is the bias that cannot be
justified by critical features
now once we have such a measure or
definition
it could be used either for auditing
that is to check if there's any non-exam
disparity present or not
it could also be used during training
for instance as a regularizer with a
loss function
to selectively reduce the non-exam
disparity
but before we get there the question is
what is a good measure of this non-exam
disparity
now to answer this question we adopt an
axiomatic approach
when we first look at some canonical
examples
and try to arrive at some desirable
properties for such a measure of
non-exam disparities
these desirable properties then lead to
one measure that satisfies these
properties
but this measure requires causality and
knowledge of the underlying causal
structure
so we also propose some observational
relaxations that do not require
the knowledge of the underlying causal
structures all the time
and then we also use these measures to
perform some case studies that can
sometimes also inform our choice of
examples and properties
now the significance of this approach is
that
these canonical examples really distill
some paradoxical scenarios that can
arise often in the context of say hiring
where a candidate measure may fail to
correctly capture what we would
intuitively like to capture in a measure
of non-exam disparity
and in doing so we also expose the pros
and cons of several candidate measures
so i'll start with some popular
definitions of fairness that is
statistical parity and equalized odds
and discuss their pros and cons
so statistical parity i guess many of
you might already be familiar with is
statistical parity says that the model
is fair if the output is entirely
independent of the sensitive attribute
like gender race etcetera
and the information theoretic measure of
statistical parity is mutual information
i'm including the definition of mutual
information here but
what this basically quantifies is the
statistical dependency between the
sensitive attribute and the final output
but statistical parity has been
criticized that it can sometimes accept
applicants who may not meet the critical
necessities
like if we again go back to our example
of hiring software engineers for a
safety critical application
let's assume that the critical feature
is correlated with the sensitive
attribute where the other features are
not
and let's say we use something like a
linear cloud we are training a linear
classifier and using this statistical
parity as a regularizer with the loss
function
then what could happen is
to reduce the mutual information between
uh the sensitive attribute and the final
output
the model may significantly reduce
emphasis on the critical feature
so if this is like the classifier that
we learn without using any kind of
fairness criteria but if we try to
incorporate statistical parity as a
regularizer the model might end up being
something like this
which reduces the emphasis on coding
test score entirely which is not
desirable
to resolve some of this some of these
issues of statistical parity another
popular definition is equalized dots
which is that the output is independent
of z conditioned on the true labels y
and a perfect classifier would always
satisfy equalized odds
but there are also some criticism
centered around equalized odds
which say that agreement with this
historic labels can sometimes propagate
biases that are already hidden in these
labels
so we again go back to the same example
and this time let's say the aptitude
test score happens to be correlated with
gender
so
this is a
let's say the uh
the points are all perfectly separable
and we learn a perfect classifier uh
using these historic labels
but then this could still be criticized
because here the disparity that we
observe is arising due to aptitude test
score which is not really a critical
feature
so the problem statement our problem
statement adopts a middle ground between
these two extremes like statistical
parity and equalized odds
that uses some domain knowledge to
identify which features are critical
and then we question that what is a good
measure of non-exam disparity which is
the bias that is not justified due to
the critical features
now
to find a measure of non-exam disparity
the first candidate measure that we can
consider is conditional dependence or
conditional mutual information
that is uh
among the candidates with the same value
of coding test score or condition on the
coding test score there is no further
dependence between
z and the final output
and the information theoretic measure
for this is conditional mutual
information which essentially captures
the conditional dependence
between z and y hat given the critical
features
but then uh
in this work we make an important
observation that conditional dependence
can sometimes falsely detect bias or
misleading dependencies
even when a model is causally fair
uh and to understand this we look at a
counter example of a causally fair model
so this time again we have this feature
coding test score
now this is the simplest possible
representation
for the coding test score which also
happens to be correlated with the
sensitive attribute
here z denotes a sensitive attribute and
u denotes a latent random variable which
is inner ability which is independent of
the sensitive attribute
and let's say the aptitude test score
happens to be just u
and the model basis is able to distill
out this true inner ability and take
decisions entirely based on u
so such a model is causally fair because
the output y hat does not uh vary with z
after fixing this inner ability u
and this is a reference for causal
definitions of fairness which
essentially say that the model is fair
from a causal perspective
if the output y hat does not have a
causal influence of this sensitive
attribute z
so this is a scenario which is fair from
these causal definitions of fairness
but then if we look at this kind of
conditioning on critical feature kind of
approach
here conditioning will say that
the mutual information is greater that
is given the critical feature
the z and y hat are not independent that
is this conditional independence does
not hold for this particular example
so this motivates a desirable property
that the measure of non-exam disparity
should be zero if the model is causally
fair
so to summarize we found that
conditional mutual information or
conditional dependence does not satisfy
this causal fairness property
and it is this limitation of conditional
mutual information
that leads us to examine this emerging
body of work and information theory
called partial information decomposition
which further decomposes conditional
mutual information into two components
called unique information and
synergistic information
and i am going to define these
quantities shortly but what we find is
that this unique information quantity
satisfies our causal fairness property
as well as some others
so what is this unique information
before formally defining it i'll try to
intuitively explain the idea through
some examples
so we look at these two examples here
for the example on the left xc z plus u
and the output is just u
so here the output y hat doesn't have
any information about the sensitive
attribute z
so in this is a case where the output is
also causally fair because it does not
depend on z
but for the example on the right the
output y hat has some information about
this gender z that is not present in
this critical feature u because xc is
just u
and y hat is z plus u here
but interestingly conditional mutual
information is the same for both of
these examples
so conditioning only on the critical
feature is not able to distinguish
between these two examples
whereas from a fairness point of view we
would like a quantity that is zero in
the first case but not zero in the
second
and so this is the desirable property
that we want to be able to distinguish
between these two cases
and this unique information measure
enables us to do that
so this is the formal definition of
unique information
it's the minimum conditional mutual
information
when only the marginals between z y hat
and z x c are preserved
but the joint distribution of these
three random variables are allowed to
vary
[Music]
and if you are interested in venn
diagrams this is a venn diagram
interpretation of unique information
so it is essentially the intersection
between just dependence and conditional
dependence
that would go to 0 whenever either of
them would go to zero
and this unique information satisfies
the causal fairness property as well as
this other property
so unique information is a good measure
for
for computing this non-exam disparity
and it's also observational in the sense
that until now it has not we have not
yet leveraged the causality structure or
the causal model or anything like that
it does have some nice properties
but then there are some more nuanced
scenarios that even unique information
is not able to address which is this
case of masking
so what is masking
so we look at the example of masking now
let us say
a hiring ad is shown to
men with high inner ability and women
with low inner ability
and it is not shown to these two
fractions of people and let's say that
all these four fractions or groups are
equally balanced
so this can be mathematically written as
an xor where the output is z x or u and
both z and u could be bernoulli half
so this is a scenario where the
statistical disparity is zero but this
model is not exactly causally fair
because this gender z
still has a causal influence on the
final output
even though from observational
standpoint we do not see any disparity
and we would find that z and y hat are
statistically independent even though
there is a causal dependence from z to y
hat
so to capture these kinds of more
nuanced examples we include another
desirable property that the non-exam
disparity should be non-zero for this
kind of example
to be able to detect this perfect
masking
and finally we have one causal measure
that satisfies all of these desirable
properties including masking
so this measure
is the unique information
uh where u a and u where u is the set of
all possible latent random variables in
our system
and u a and ub is a partition of all of
those latent random variables
and as you can see this measure depends
on the causal structure and requires
knowledge of the latent random variables
but we are able to show that this
measure satisfies the properties that i
talked about as well as some natural
monotonicity properties as well
like if all the features are critical it
will be zero and it's monotonic as we
include more and more features in the
critical set
and it becomes
zero if all the feat if none of the
features are critical then it's equal to
the total causal uh unfairness
so again as i said this measure depends
on the on the latent random variables
and on the causal structure
but we believe there is some value to
first finding a measure that
actually captures uh satisfies all the
desirable properties however complex it
might be to understand or compute
because then it can serve as a benchmark
for all these other observational
measures and help us understand to what
extent they are close to the
original measure
and another important aspect is that the
unique information the observational
unique information measure that i talked
about
is actually lower bound for this measure
and it is actually good enough for a lot
of situations except to capture these
kinds of perfect masking scenarios and
it is only to be able to capture these
kinds of perfectly masked scenarios that
we need to
go into this latent random variable
understand these later random variables
and causal structures
i just want to clarify the statement
here so you're saying you give any
causal graph with any number of latent
variables
going in whatever direction you want
this is guaranteed to satisfy the six
properties yes this this quantity will
satisfy these six problems and these
properties are stated informal in the
top but they are written formally in
so i can do some intuition on the
proposed measure
uh so one might first think that if is
non-exam disparity guarantee default
causal paths from z to y hat pass
through the critical feature
but
we'll have this kind of examples with
some confounding effects where this may
not always hold so this is a case of
disparity amplification
where again we have these two features z
plus u and u
but this time the model does something
weird it can subtract out u and only
begins to base its decisions on z
so this is a case of disparity
amplification where seemingly less
biased features are mixing to produce a
heavily biased output y hat
which is equal to z
and here these kinds of causal paths are
passing through xc but this u has this
kind of a confounding effect which is
causing this
problem
so in general
there can be three types of latent
random variables ones that only
influence xc
ones that only influence y hat
and ones that can have this kind of a
effect on both of them
now when this third kind of random
variable goes of latent random variable
goes away we can choose u a to be u1 and
ub to be these variables
and this kind of a conditional
independence will hold
but then when we have all these kinds of
relations like u3 is there and z also
can have other
paths to y hat
then this conditional independence may
not hold for all partitions of u and ub
so then uh we saw that conditional
mutual information can sometimes capture
misleading dependencies
so we use unique information as our
proposed measure
and this gap denotes the kind of
misleading dependencies that could arise
when
we do not really want our measure to be
non-zero
but the conditional mutual information
happens to be nonzero
and this is also an upper bound for this
measure of unique information that we
are trying to compute
so in essence this
gives us non-negative decomposition of
the total causal disparity into exempt
and non-exempt components
but we have a subsequent decomposition
in the paper as well which further
decomposes
this total causal disparity
into four components that is visible and
non-exempt and visible exempt
and also must non-exempt and must accept
and
one in
one aspect about this kind of
decomposition is that this is a
non-negative decomposition so unlike
causal decompositions where the
components can be positive or negative
and they could add to something but here
all of these components are non negative
so if the
total causal disparity is zero all of
the things inside the venn diagram also
becomes zero
so then we move on to observational
measures because this measure required
the knowledge of the latent random
variables so what can we do
from purely observational perspective
and ah as we might uh expect that we
have this impossibility result that
purely observational measures cannot
satisfy all of these six desirable
properties
but with some partial knowledge or
assumptions about the causal
relationships they can correctly
quantify non-exam
disparity so these are some
observational measures that we could use
potentially for scenarios where the
causal latent structure is not known
i've only talked about mutual
information and unique information and
this is like a more heuristic kind of
mutual information where you could if
you have partial knowledge about some
random variables you could choose to
condition on some more random variables
than the critical feature
and then we have some case studies uh
for auditing as well as training where
we use these observational measures of
non-exam disparity
so we get these kinds of we have some
sim we use simulated data first because
for simulated data we actually know the
ground truth and we can compute our
measure
so we are able to compute total causal
disparity as well as compute these kinds
of exempt and non-exempt disparities
and when we use them as a regularizer
with the loss function uh these are the
kinds of plots we get like we find that
accuracy decreases and these
regularizers also tend to decrease the
original non-exempt disparity this is
the actual causal measure of non-exam
disparity and we are seeing how
well these observational regularizers
are able to reduce that
and again for computing them in practice
i have used a lot of approximations like
i've
approximated them using correlations and
made some gaussian assumptions but
so there's a potential for even
improving the estimators for these
quantities
then
yeah then we also look at other
scenarios where there's actually no
causal disparity here we see mutual
information
falsely tries to reduce non-exam
disparity when there isn't any but
unique information doesn't
and then these are other scenarios where
there's some masking and in masked
scenarios sometimes conditioning can
help reduce some kinds of mass
disparities which unique information
again doesn't address
and then these are some experiments on
real data again because these
regularizers are observational they can
be computed on real data but it's
difficult to verify whether
they are actually reducing the original
non-exam disparity because we do not
know the structural causal models here
but nonetheless these observational
relaxations can be used for auditing or
training purposes
uh and we also perform some experiments
on the cmu ec graduate admissions data
set where we looked at these quantities
the observational quantities and looked
at the partial dec information
decomposition of
mutual information and conditional
mutual information on the admissions
data set
so summary before we move on uh this
work provides a systematic approach to
finding a measure of non-exam disparity
and conditional mutual information or
naively conditioning on features can
falsely detect disparities even if they
are causally fair
but unique information doesn't falsely
detect disparity but then it can
sometimes miss these kinds of masking
effects
and there's of uh there's potential for
future work like finding improved
estimators for these quantities as well
as some broader conversations that this
work opens like how do we interpret or
understand laws for algorithmic hiring
and it is essential to collaborate with
lawyers and social scientists to be able
to fully understand this picture
of algorithmic fairness where
there's like critical features and then
there are some disparities which are
exempt and some disparities which are
not exempt
so now i'll very briefly mention some
other problems that i'm also working on
so this is a problem this applies the
similar kinds of ideas to a different
application uh which is the problem of
filter bubbles in social media
so filter bubbles refer to a state of
intellectual isolation where a user is
only exposed to content that you like
and agree with and you do not get to see
the other side of the debate like if you
like new york times you get
you get recommendations from new york
times if you like fox news you only get
recommendations from fox news
so here uh we
use this idea of uh computing exempt and
non-exam topic biases where a user gets
to select certain topics that are really
critical or important for them
whereas there are some topics that are
less important for the user and we are
able to compute these kinds of exempt
and non-exam topic biases using a
similar idea
and this is another problem that i've
been looking into this is slightly
different from the problem that i'm
talking i was talking about because this
uses some other measures of fairness
so this is a question on uh is there a
trade-off between accuracy and fairness
this is a problem that is uh
also gaining significant interest in the
fairness community
and uh while there have been several
empirical and theoretical papers that
have pointed out
towards the existence of this trade-off
but
there's been relatively less work on how
do we quantify this trade-off or how do
we understand how much does accuracy
fall for how much
reduction in bias or disparity
so in this work we use these tools
called churn of exponents as
approximations to the actual error
exponents in binary classification
uh so
and the nice thing about churn of
exponents is that they have a nice
geometric interpretability which helps
us quantify the trade-off between
accuracy and discrimination
in terms of these churn of exponents
so here i use a measure of fairness
which is close to equalized odds or
equal opportunity which is the equality
of false negative exponents for the two
groups
and a sweet spot will be here that is we
want high accuracy and low
discrimination
and we introduce this concept of
separability which
using churn of information which
quantifies the best possible accuracy
exponent that you can get for a
particular group
so then we are able to compute these
kinds of tradeoffs where
the optimal but unfair classifier would
be over
here and the fair but sub optimal
classifiers would be somewhere over
there
and we also show that if you're able to
somehow get more information about the
data set like neither through gathering
more features or
refining your experiment then sometimes
the separability can possibly improve
and if the separability or information
theoretic bound improves then the
trade-off can also be alleviated
so now the optimal but fair classifier
unfair classifier would be here and the
fair words of optimal classifier would
be over there
and we also show that there are ideal
distributions with respect to which
there may not be any trade-off
so looking forward these are some
questions that i'm interested in one
question that i'm in particularly
interested in is this feature
engineering or problems in the feature
selection space
because the problem is not always very
neat and clean where we have a set of
features and we just have to make the
model fair but even in the feature
engineering space there can be thousands
of features and there can be lot of
debate on which features could be used
which features couldn't be used
and then there could be further debates
on whether this feature is contributing
to the bias or whether this other
feature is contributing
so that's another space where i'm very
interested in and there are also
problems like training models with
restricted access to certain features
like you are not able to allow not able
to use
gender race or even zip code to be able
to train your models or to make them
fair
uh then another problem that i'm also
getting interested in is this
uh problem at the intersection of
partial information decomposition and
causality
so this is not really related to
fairness but generally i want to
understand whether partial information
decomposition has an interpretation in
causality or causal dags
for instance in these two situations the
conditional mutual information is
greater than zero in both these cases
but
when c is a child of both a and b then
the unique information becomes zero and
the entire information is synergistic
information
whereas when it's not a child in that
kind of setting the synergistic
information is zero whereas the unique
information is not
so yeah my research mission is uh to
build the foundations of reliable
machine learning uh that are deep rooted
in foundations of information theory
causality and statistics
and connecting it to different
applications thank you so much
any questions
um
so
uh though the i guess i was thinking
about your earlier examples and like you
had uh this causal awareness which had
to do with these
variables but um
when
like
or whatever yeah i guess it's
coming up with an algorithm that doesn't
have access to that same variable but
it's uh when it has to be audited um
like against those is there a way of
kind of
measuring the metric of like that
unfairness that's due to the fact that
this un observed variable is you know
related as opposed to what's the amount
of fairness that could be
uh
closed algorithmically sorry that makes
sense so like like i could have a
like the best the minimum unfairness i
could get uh limited to the fact that i
i'm only allowed to use observed data
versus that and that might already be a
non-zero unfairness right so but then
there's an additional like i'm very
because i'm using that
yeah so what you're saying is like uh
suppose you know that you will not have
access to the latent random variables
then can i give guarantees on
this much fairness i can still remove
and this is the part of fairness that
has been not able to create okay
yeah i think uh these uh this lower
bounds that i was showing before um
the
unique information let me go back
so here this unique information this is
actually uh this one is an observational
quantity
so you could remove that much of
unfairness uh surely
and this will be like this gap will be
like the extra unfairness that you're
not able to remove
but then there are also like upper
bounds that are observational so you
could also remove more unfairness but at
the cost of falsely removing some
dependencies or falsely accounting for
certain dependencies
so that was a question
any other questions so
so you do so you found this approach
that the people in information theory do
when they put the access to these most
things to satisfy it that you derive the
things
but but with fairness you know you can
argue about these things about what
actions
how do you think about that what if
somebody comes to you and says i don't
believe in accident number three
that you propose in my application or
how does that tie to examples like
your experience are there various
settings where like when you some
accidents are satisfied with others
yeah that's that's a good question uh
yeah so i think even when we use these
kinds of observational relaxations like
this uh previous example that i was
talking about
so here uh if we do not care for say
these kinds of scenarios where like
perfect masking is happening
then we could probably drop this axiom
and say these are five axioms and maybe
an observational measure will satisfy
these five examples so that could uh uh
happen and
uh i think that these axioms are also
each action is connected to some set of
canonical examples and they give some
insight on what kind of fairness you
want in one particular scenario or one
particular distilled scenario where
other kinds of dependencies are not
arising so as long as you are interested
in addressing that particular kind of
dependency you might want to include
that axiom but i agree with you that i
mean there's no guarantee as such that
these are the six axioms that
should be followed or uh
like there are no other possible axioms
or why we shouldn't just drop one axiom
because yeah even some of the
observational measures
are not satisfying all six they're
satisfying any five or any three so i
think these exams help you group
canonical examples in some sense
uh into different categories
do you have any sense there are other
measures that could satisfy all these
assumptions
yeah so i think yeah that uniqueness is
also something that is not yet shown so
yeah there could be uh other measures
that also satisfy these six exams yes
any other questions
all right let's take this speaker one
more time